this was so close to perfect okay folks
it's time for another installment of
knit picker rants and add this one I'm
going to take a look at one of my
favorite movies from the past few years
dawn of the Planet of the Apes I really
love this movie I loved Rise of the
Planet of the Apes that that one really
surprised me it came I don't know where
it was awesome when I thought it was
going to be junk and then this one even
better it raised the stakes on
everything Caesar was such an amazing
character Andy Serkis plays him so well
and the way just the story navigated
what it was doing it went in unexpected
directions it didn't take the obvious
route and it just kicked a whole lot of
butt but there's one tiny little thing
and it tucked me out of the film even as
I was watching in the theater for the
first time and as always this isn't it
pick this is a tiny thing it doesn't
matter but it drives me nuts when did
the H we load this this really does
drive me nuts because honestly I take no
issue with the image of an a dual
wielding machine guns on horseback that
is an awesome image I will not question
it however the Apes while they seem to
have an understanding and awareness of
guns or something dangerous we don't see
that they've ever actually picked them
up and use them before Koba gets his
hands on one and you know they are smart
creatures they know how to you know
figure stuff out I'll buy picks it up
into it's how to use the thing he gets
just a big guy cool can roll with that
but at no point is Koba or Teddy ape
involved in that raid shown to ever
reload a gun I literally I just need one
one shot at one point of the one ape
real
just to prove to me that they figured
out how to do that I don't even need to
question the fact that you know they're
Apes they're naked day of nowhere to put
magazines of ammo I'll even set that one
aside just show me the point of which so
I know that they figured that part out
because I don't think reloading
if you don't really understand fully
guns beyond the idea of pointing pull
trigger I don't think that's intuitive
enough that you can just assume that
that they figured out how to reload show
me that I mean maybe even show me the
stockpile any ammo a little bit but at
the very least show me that they know
how to reload because I'm watching that
make sure the humans reloading at a few
points and you know they're there
you'll pin down and I see them real oh
but the Apes just come boom they got
infinite ammo and they never reload
penny it also would work if you know the
guns had run out of ammo they threw it
aside and started using another gun that
was already fully loaded that would work
too but they don't do that they keep
using the same guns over and over and
the mo never runs out and they never
reload but obviously we're not dealing
with him but in a no rules because the
you would have to reload my if it was
what time yielding pretty giveth if they
had put it in the movie yet I would have
wait laid this little thing in my head
that couldn't let it go so that is this
particular nitpick grant so yeah your
thoughts on this didn't occur to you
that they never showed that thieves knew
how to reload or ever did or have I just
ruined an epically awesome movie for you
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast and the and or the
punch like a girl podcast both available
on iTunes and stitcher until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]